hey what is up guys mkbhd here and it's
the beginning of 2014 and there are a
lot of great tablet options out there to
buy so many in fact that i think it
needs more than just one person to give
perspective on it all so in
collaborative fashion to kick off the
new year in no particular order these
are the five best tablets that you can
buy right now so i'm gonna kick it off
with
the nexus 10 already a weird pick i know
but this actually deserves a spot in
what i would say one of the best tablets
of the year because it has two main
things that distinguish it from the rest
number one it has a large bright
beautiful high resolution display
and it has
front-facing speakers and the only other
tablet that has that right now is the
galaxy note 10.1 2014 edition but of
course this is a nexus so it's running
the latest version of stock android and
we'll get updates faster than ever right
now it has android 4.4 kitkat and that
kind of breathes new life into hardware
like this because kitkat has lower
system requirements so even though this
is technically
well two years old now this year it'll
turn two years old uh it still has great
specs and runs 4.4 kitkat flawlessly so
even if it doesn't have the latest
bleeding edge high-end specs ultimately
this is one of my favorite tablet
experiences because when you use a
tablet for the most part when i'm using
a tablet it's to watch videos watch
movies even
read magazines and books browse the web
and just consume media and the
combination of a super high res large
display and front-facing speakers with
the latest version of android make it
perfect for consuming media and that's
why i still use mine to this day even
though it was released in 2012
so fingers crossed that the next version
of the nexus 10 which is probably coming
out soon also has front-facing speakers
what's up guys lou here and my tablet
selection is the new nexus 7 from google
all right so it's not so new anymore but
it's still a fantastic choice in the
tablet marketplace and a great value
it's got a competitive price point it's
got a pixel dense display it's running
the stock or vanilla android experience
meaning you're going to get updates
right away and you don't have any
unnecessary bloat on top of the os so
it's going to be snappy in operation and
require less resources if you don't know
already i'm a huge fan of vanilla
android devices this form factor is also
nice and pocketable at least in a jacket
pocket so all around the nexus 7 is a
great selection definitely check it out
if you haven't yet i'm a big fan i think
you will be too it'll also pick up your
kids from school if you need it to
i'm just kidding
or am i
hey what's up guys i'm mark otherwise
known as soldier knows best and one of
my favorite tablets of 2013 is going to
be the ipad air you can't really go
wrong with the ipad air designer wise
the build quality can't really be
matched by any tablet in the 9.7 or 10
inch form factor then also the internals
with the dual core a7 processor which on
paper may sound bad because it's dual
core but it's really packing a lot of
heat and you combine that with the new
m7 motion co-processor this is going to
allow developers to have a lot of
flexibility when it comes to making apps
for this ipad and really take advantage
of all the hardware and push it to its
limits and of course it is running a new
ios 7 which may be in for some people uh
but the cameras on the ipad at least are
really good again i don't know how many
people actually be using the cameras on
this thing but if you do need to it has
the best cameras on the tablet that i
personally use so with the starting
price being 4.99 this may not be the
best bang for your buck but if you're
looking for one of the best all-around
tablets you can't go wrong with the ipad
air what is going on mkbhders this is
jonathan from tld and my pick for one of
the top five tablets of 2013 is the lg g
pad 8.3 and specifically the google play
edition now as far as tablets go i think
the eight inch form factor at least for
me anyways is the sweet spot and because
we have a gap between the nexus 7 and
the nexus 10 with this running pure
android 4.4 kitkat this is the closest
thing to a nexus 8 that we currently
have
it's got a beautiful brushed aluminum
back it's only 8.3 millimeters thin and
has super thin and sexy bezels so if you
hate big clunky bezels you're probably
going to be attracted towards this guy
it also features a killer 1920x1200 full
hd display a snapdragon 600 quad-core
processor expandable storage via microsd
twin hd cameras and a 4600 milliamp hour
battery so you're gonna get some killer
battery life whether you're browsing the
web watching movies or playing games so
i think you can see why this made my
list if you have been looking for an
8-inch tablet you didn't want to go the
apple route and you want that pure
unadulterated android experience this is
probably the perfect option for you my
favorite tablet of 2013 is the apple
ipad mini retina so it was actually
never really a big fan of the original
ipads that always just seemed a little
bit too big and too bulky for me but
when the ipad mini came along i was
absolutely sold however there were a
couple major problems such as the lack
of a retina display something that well
the ipad mini retina doesn't have any
problem with it's sporting a 7.9 inch
2048 by 1536 screen which in my opinion
is a really good sweet spot so this is
something i can still use in one hand
still very lightweight i can hold it up
forever it's no big deal but it also
does give you enough screen real estate
to be able to browse the web and all
that sort of thing there's a lot more to
like about the new ipad mini including
the awesome battery life as well as the
super fast apple a7 processor which is
shared with the ipad air as well as the
iphone 5s but you put it all together
and in my opinion not only is this the
best title of 2013 but the best tablet
period
so there you go guys those are the five
best tablets in our opinions that are
available to buy right now here at the
beginning of 2014 after the holidays uh
but obviously there are things that we
didn't even mention that aren't in the
top five there is the sony xperia tablet
z easily the sexiest tablet you can buy
right now if that's what you value
there's the samsung galaxy tab 10.1 2014
edition there's a kindle fire hdx
there's the microsoft surface pro 2. uh
there's a ton
but ultimately the number one pick comes
down to whatever you pick what is your
pick feel free to leave that in the
comment section below that like button
and also right below that like button
will be the links to all the awesome
youtube channels that contributed to
this video so it'll be annotations and
links below to check out all those
channels so if you want to see more from
those guys you can feel free and check
out the rest of the videos they have and
their styles on their channels so that's
been it thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed and of course another video is
coming up very soon so make sure you
subscribe if you haven't already to see
that and uh like tomorrow basically is
when it's coming out and so let's get
this new year started off on a great
note again thanks for watching i'll talk
to you guys in the next video
peace
you